come dire siamo ragazzi su era tutt che
sarebbe il mio nome da rapper secondo
fede c'è un tizio che sta strangolando
che cazzo è sta roba
sto partendo per spiegarvi un po che
cos'è sto gioco che non lo so ma più o
meno
ho letto la trama è più o meno capito
capito si fa per dire che fatto adatti a
tumulo prigione va bene ci sono questi
prigionieri
c'è qualcuno che fa esperimenti e ci
sono dei ratti radio tv allora è
veramente molto strano il fatto che
stiano facendo esperimenti sui topi
allora mi sembra un po eccessivo cioè
nel senso giampiero non mi sembra il
caso di giocare a fantasista re on line
mentre con tizio è diventato un ragno io
voglio smettere di fare lo youtuber
adesso cosa cazzo sto vedendo ragazzi ci
stanno iniettando delle robe ma che
schifo
quello poverino poverino colori balzate
bravo bravo bravo libera gli altri vera
gli altri c'è ma che quanto manca per
asta scena c'è un tizio diventato un
ragno penso che piuttosto preferirei
morire atrocemente in qualsiasi altro
modo ma non diventare un ragno ragazzi
va bene che schifo ancora festa lo
scherzo cristo è tanto quello paventato
dice io chi sono
mi chiedo anch'io sto punto così come si
fa come si fa come come secure come
faccio a ok perfetto madonna o l'avete
fatto voi e siete [ __ ] non è
colpa mia
c'è stato niente andò siero di qualcosa
ma questo qua anche nemico e anche
nemico nostro l'abbiamo scoperto adesso
è bene quindi ha quindi ci sono nove
bellissimo suo gioco ci sono modi per
ora vado contro sto tizio non mi sparare
per favore testa di culo mia fritto il
cervello ci sono modi per scappare ma
non so quali possono trarre centro in
questo chiedo
non aprire non aprire quelli in fondo ha
bisogno a perché c'è il topo che cade
carlos e il dopo che gira allora aperto
quello che perfetto perfetto mi sono
salvato non sono come lei alla caccia
dei ratti mutanti molti di voi non sanno
neanche di che sto parlando ma questo
gioco è identico a prince of persia ma
non presolana play collo proprio
lovecchio lo posso spingere proprio lui
è veramente similissimo preso per
ragazzi mi dà una vice di prince of
persia pazzesco mi sono anche fumato la
sigaretta perché sono trans che è
fantastico è il salto nei di sotto ma
secondo me non devo andare 18 con
dall'altra parco si salta non mi proprio
a così aspettate busnago hard rock e
perfetto perfetto proprio lui va donna
l'altro questo qua ha perso la testa
mentre cadeva mi sembra un po esagerato
sta cosa va beh
ebbene io sto gioco bene mi date una
mano brutti stronzi io faccio io faccio
tutto io vasi tanto guarda dunque bravo
grava lo sanno
c'è veramente aiuto o meno di zero e
ragazzi i complimenti ma c'è un modo per
correre che non solo ha sì c'è un modo
per correre ma non è che se passa a loro
poi esco ciabatta ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho
fatta non so come non so come le tv
dottore you should be there are going up
trend based
aspetta aspetta che dobbiamo mettere se
non è cosa che succede qualcosa di
bruttissimo osservate una valvola ma per
qualità email
però nel fatto che sono i bidoni
l'elemento garbage nell'immondizia
non ho capito il cesto tizio che
scappavano capito il motivo perchè ha
rubato una ventola ma che cazzo ne
fregano fatto una ventola mica è mia
occhio che poi scelto post mettili frate
non mi sembra proprio il modo più un
safe ma perché sto seguendo sto tizio
quel problema se ne frega a me di
soddisfare watt e fattibile casi provate
tutte le manovelle che vuoi non sono ne
frega a me di caccia
ecco io vorrei indietro se please
l'italiano proprio in testa sankei di
saleh no poletti le armi la manovella no
vabbè porca [ __ ] ma che solo fare su e
messa trasmessa tutto addosso capi non
vada avanti
risalta io andavo avanti e devi correre
aiuto adesso madonna dopo le schivare
ragazzi aiuto la pazzesca sta roba
ma non ha rigiocato fatto ragazzi a sto
giocando benissimo il primo tentativo e
ragazzi pazzesco porca un pazzesco
pazzesco
yes a volte oddio apre la bella modella
premia pendeva nel proprio occhio che si
scende perfetto non ci ho fatto
incredibile incredibile a devo mettere
attenzione devo distribuire il fluido
equivalente mi date una mano voi state
fermi tutto il tempo a non fare un cazzo
ci ho messo sei ore non so come va bene
sono uscito
arrivederci stato è stato come figo è
successo veramente strade i giochi più
strani io abbia mai fatto questo sta
guardando la avete perso avete perso
vinto che abbiamo intorno agli europei
note che voleva solo fare qua ci siano
nascondere allo store discorso di
scooter bene gli avrei fatto questo
rumore sono bevendo la birra con ci
guardiamo la partita ragazze ci siamo
allora c'è un coso qua datemi una mano
cioè chiavi che servono ho trovato le
chiavi top ha le chiavi le manette
handicap vuol dire manette e io lo
sapevo lo so vedremo i dazi e vado io
strano che vado io e non è mai successo
che è sembrato prima i ragazzi meno male
quindi insomma cosa succede quando
salivo orribile prova però a non mi sa
che questo non è per
credo che questo sia per quello dopo ok
non si apre e vado a vedere io vado
vedere io dai tranquilli merda veloci
passerà sopra ma avevo persi perché può
andare solo uno porca [ __ ] santo
iddio 9 per ragazzi concentrato pazzesco
questa frase può avere un doppio senso
ok ok ho fatto tutto giusto
torri che tempismo di merda 9 devo fare
tutto giusto la credibile che ansia che
asia ma no ma basta ridere oddio che
pezzo di merda no ma dai
cioè i ragazzi impossibile bellissimo
no ok ma donna pero mai mi sono salvato
vai giù pazzesco la capace scorsa la
sala partita la partita salvala salvala
era sangue è tutto a posto tutto fosse
usato sangue possono notare tranquillo
tran go e trango e euro
cos'è sta roba
io mi muoverei da qui corri c'è un
bottone da premere mi ha mangiato la
testa va bene no no scusami nota e per
favore non facciamo i seri per cortesia
e devo ricordarmi schiacciate il tasto
non è proprio così scontato e io lo
farei io lo schiacci e ray adesso qua
avrei messo c'è poi signori però non
mettetelo tranquilli tanto ci sono tutta
una animazione di mezzo madonna che culo
arrivederci
vedo che anche gli altri comunque stanno
messi bene una ma ragazzi ma che cazzo
dici come è pazzesco sto gioco no l'ha
definita peccato comunque no è proprio
figo e proprio figo figo figo spero che
cosa continua e molto gol però si fa
giocare molto vecchio stile
bravi complimenti spero che sia piaciuto
ragazzi questa era tutt ora cruz casato
cose il ragazzino il momento mi piace
anche al risorgimento descrizione è come
se avete perso la voce che porco del
demonio iscrivetevi a un proprio video
dai ragazzi
[Musica]